estelle bonjour à vous êtes place du
trocadéro ou à lui un rassemblement
statique sur à peine notamment de
personnalités politiques
quelles sont les revendications des
manifestants eh bien écoutez amira tout
d'abord sachez qu'ils sont plusieurs
centaines à être rassemblés à issy place
du trocadéro vous allez d'ailleurs
pouvoir le voir sur ces images de à
didier un mulot des manifestants qui
protestent contre eux à l'extension du
pass sanitaires mais aussi contre la
vaccination obligatoire pour certaines
professions
je propose d'écouter ces quelques
manifestants à qui nous avons pu parler
depuis le début on nous dit beaucoup de
choses mais tout et son contraire
là par exemple depuis des mois on nous
dit faut tester vacciner isolé et cetera
sauf que lorsque le pass va être en
action la dir les tests ne seront plus
remboursés à partir de là qu'est ce qui
va se passer on sera plus qui est malade
or on sait que le vaccin ne protège pas
de la maladie complètement les gens
peuvent être malade est contagieux mais
ça évidemment le gouvernement va le
masquer complètement mais je suis ici
pour la liberté de tout le monde de
vacciner des nouveaux axes idées et pour
protéger mes enfants mes petits-enfants
parce que d'y un recul liberté pourquoi
pourquoi scinder la france en deux
après la fausse epu égalité liberté
égalité fraternité c'est ça sanitaires
c'est qu'on a plus de liberté
c'est à dire que ça va nous priver de
liberté on est dans un pays liberté
égalité fraternité
quoiqu'il ait inventé ces voilà c'est
comme ça depuis le début et et il est
vrai que on sait très bien qu'on va être
privé de douala de faire ce qu'on veut
quand on veut et ça doit pas être alors
ce rassemblement à deraa il est en train
d'organiser un par florian philippot le
président d'ea patriotes et anciens à
bras droit de marine le pen qui appelle
non seulement au boycott du pass
sanitaires mais aussi au lieu à kiel
obligeant je vous rappelle que depuis
mercredi il est obligatoire pour les
lieux culturels comme par exemple les
cinémas un rassemblement statique donc
ici au cours duquel et bien vous allez
le voir à ma gauche des prises de parole
sont organisés et vont être organisées
tout au long de cette journée sachez que
la semaine dernière 114 114 mille
personnes avaient défilé dans les rues
de l'hexagone dont dix-huit mille à
paris contre l'extension de ce pass and
i ter selon les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur